hello I'm Raymond holt are you here to
turn yourself in James aha whose aims
Colin haimes the Freestyle killer he
took out an entire four by 100 meter
relay swim team in 1982 mark oh no you
say polo oh I have more arrests than
anyone where you please tell the captain
how dumb it is to lock his best
detective in a file cabinet second best
you wrong about hole that man has
forgotten more about being a cop than
you will ever know
in 1981 you caught the disco strangler
it's over disco man put down the yo-yo
and back away from the girl Wow somehow
that doesn't surprise me
something Horrible's happened and I
don't know what to do has captain Holt
ever told you about the Brooklyn broiler
yeah arsonist burned down 12 buildings
in Crown Heights captain's told me about
it many times you flamed out dirtbag I
need to focus on my reelection campaign
clear my schedule you really care about
this little Club huh the club it's an
organization that I founded over 25
years ago I'm proud to say we now have
50 members but it wasn't so easy in the
beginning I'd like to request
discretionary funds to start an
organization supporting black gay and
lesbian police officers
[Laughter]
he is still finally figures his agent in
the FBI I think it's time for me to call
in a favor from an old colleague at the
bureau Bob Anderson I would have
contacted him sooner but this is a rogue
op and he's a real stickler for the
rules he once picked up a penny off the
street which he then reported on his
taxes sounds like a barrel of laughs
fortunately he isn't we worked together
back in the day and really hit it off
we're gonna be here a while would you
like to talk I'd rather not agreed this
brings back memories
I love playing doctor as a child cancer
spread get your house in order we're
doomed the minute she's slithered into
the precinct it's funny when we first
met we had some good times looks like we
both want that stapler seems that way
based on what happened so when did it
all go south 1989 that was up for a big
promotion which would have fast-tracked
my career lunch offered to write a
letter on my behalf but instead she
torpedoed me because of something that
happened the night before she was to
turn it in Madeline
would you care for a drink I'd love one
I'm sure you can tell I'm quite drunk
I've had a couple that build up the
nerve I think we both know what I'm
about to say Raymond I don't think we
need to say anything I'm gay that's what
I was going to tell you well then she
sabotage my career because I refused to
bed her can I confess something to you I
didn't throw Frederick's duck in the
garbage
yes I know sir I didn't throw the duck
in the garbage
I threw it off a bridge I would talk to
him but I don't think I have any advice
all my breakups have been completely
mutual this is the best possible option
for both of us a great stake here that
was the end of an eight-year
relationship I think it would help if we
knew why we were doing these jobs
because I ordered you to resume the
drill Timmy and do not do or say
anything that a seven-year-old boy would
not do or say feel free to consult the
script I've prepared okay but it's a
little stilted I am feeling trepidation
at the prospect of a parentless
existence no kid talks like that those
lines were lifted verbatim from my
boyhood diary you know I don't like to
talk about this but many years ago I
myself overcame an addiction I could not
get enough of the ponies go razzmataz
go razzmataz go razzmataz
hello service gonna spend the rest of
your life in a little submitter room
doing nothing
and while you're in there I'm gonna go
for a swim and after that swim my big
another swim and you'll just be sitting
on your metal toilet thinking of me swim
swim swimming
oh they love when I get out of lockup
I'm gonna hunt you down and kill you
yeah trying to lighten the mood the
squad's been stressed since these drills
started plus you ordered me to act like
a seven-year-old seven-year-olds liked
to have fun
that's true when I was seven I used to
sneak into my father's office to see his
collection of antique globes what did
the efficients say when you got married
not much when gay marriage was legalized
we weren't sure if or when it was gonna
be struck down so speed was of the
essence do you Kevin yes and to you yes
yes we don't we're married I remarked
afterwards that I wish the old ficient
had been more efficient it was very
funny Kevin still talks about it I got
it working with that thing
you